Speaker 1: All right. Next, I want to look
at a very strange interview that Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert gave to Dave Rubin
now some in the audience who are familiar with
Dave Rubin, some are not. Dave Rubin's former
Twitty Young Turks host, who was ostensibly on
the left. He had a political awakening around the
age of 40 years old, close to 40 years old, which
some don't believe is genuine some believe is
based in audience capture, grifting and financial
incentives, up to others to determine that he is
now very, very after kind of playing that he's the
last real liberal role for a few years. He now is
on the right. He's a right winger, he said. He's
OK being called a right winger. He says he voted
for Trump. He, you know, et cetera, et cetera. And
he gives an interview that would make North
Korean propaganda newscasters blush. I mean,
really what? We're going to look at this interview
and there's sort of a couple of different types of
context here. One is we just learned about
Lauren Boebert alleged role in planning the
January six Trump riots that she or staffers were
involved in talking to the organizers along with
others. We talked about this Rolling Stone article
yesterday. That's one context here. And then the
second context is, again, just like the brazen and
embarrassing nature of this interview altogether.
So let's just get into the first clip and this
is just again, this this is like the cultural
stuff. Here's Lauren Boebert saying because of
the mask mandates, she's pulling her kids right
out of school and now is partially homeschooling.
Speaker 4: I just pulled my kids out of public
school because they brought back mask mandates
and they're not letting up on it. And they said,
OK, well, we're doing something else because
I'm not subjecting my children to this again.
And and so we're we're pulling them
out and doing something on our own.
Speaker 2: But are you homeschooling now?
Speaker 4: It will be a hybrid
version of homeschooling.
Speaker 1: It's a hybrid. She'll be hybrid
homeschooling. Is it good for kids who presumably
have community at school, who presumably have some
friends at school, et cetera, to be told? Little
Johnny, little Susie. You're not going to wear
a mask now. You're going to sit at home and
we're going to teach you it's hybrid. Who knows
what they really mean. Like, is that even good
for the kid? I don't know. But it doesn't seem
super great. Then Lauren Boebert blames Nancy
Pelosi for division in the House. It's not that
Republicans have stopped even pretending to be
about policy and obstructing anything Democrats
want to do. It's not that Republicans
are totally hypocritical on every issue.
Gladly voting for Trump's COVID relief. But then
when Biden is in voting against it, even though
it's very similar, it's just a few months later.
But she says it's Nancy Pelosi's fault. And Ruben,
just he's on board with all of it. There was
there's just no challenging of anything, she says
Speaker 4: to keep us so divided and so separate
and previous members of Congress who've been
there previously, they'll tell you it's never
been this way. There was always communication
between Republicans and Democrats,
Speaker 1: now part of. She may be
right that it's never been this way, but it's
this we've never had such weaponized, outrageous
Trumpian members of Congress making it this way.
Speaker 4: And now it is so divided and that's by
design. She wants to keep us separate.
She wants the house chambers empty.
You're talking about you're talking about
Nancy. Nancy Pelosi. Yes, yes. And she
truly believes this is Pelosi's House.
Speaker 1: And yeah. And Ruben's just
nodding. Yo yo yo yo yo yo. This is a propaganda
interview. This is what you would expect to see
on that North Korean channel or on, you
know, Venezuelan state media or whatever.
It's it's what it is here, as if this is
funny. Lauren Boebert smiles and laughs
at the idea that they've installed metal
detectors at the house because of her,
as if it's something to be proud of.
Speaker 4: Nancy Pelosi has called me the
enemy within. We have metal detectors outside
of the House chambers because of me and so so.
Speaker 1: Yeah, if you know, if your employer has
had to institute security measures as a result of
your actions, it's not something I'd be cheering
about. Imagine if I remember my Circuit City days
that I've talked about so nostalgically on the
program. Imagine if when I worked at Circuit
City. Circuit City installed metal detectors
that employees had to go through because of me,
because of something I did, and then I bragged
about it. That's what she's doing. That's how
outrageous this has gotten. And then they get
into, I guess, what you would call something more
substantive, even though it's not substantive
because Ruben doesn't even question it. Lauren
Boebert says her objection to the Electoral
College was results being counted was that it
violated the Constitution and Rubins just nodding.
Speaker 4: I objected to the Electoral College
results because the Constitution was violated,
right? And that's our biggest threat right now
is the complete disregard of the Constitution.
Speaker 1: Now the Constitution was not violated.
All of these talking points have been widely
debunked. As usual, it's hard to understand the
exact argument they're making. Sometimes
they say, well, it was unconstitutional,
and it's not, she's saying federal constitution.
Some say state it was unconstitutional that
states changed election procedures without
legislation. That's actually no big deal.
Rebecca Green, an election law professor at the
College of William and Mary, said it is often the
case that there are gaps in election statutes that
state and local election officials routinely fill,
according to their authority. So to say that all
decisions about how elections are run must emanate
from the Legislature is not consistent with
delegated authority to state election officials.
It's a lie that it's unacceptable to change
election rules without legislation in states.
They're repeating it, but it's just not true.
Then many states changed election practices
because of the pandemic. That includes blue
states. That includes red states. It includes
states in which Trump won. It includes states in
which Biden won. Big shocker. They only care about
the fact that it was done in states that Biden
won. So North Dakota Red State Trump won changed
voting rules due to the pandemic. You don't hear
a peep out of these people, Arkansas or Kansas,
as some used to say Arkansas Red State Trump
won changed election rules due to the pandemic.
What they'd never mention Arkansas, Texas, they
all made changes in this way. On the basis of
the pandemic, Trump won all three. Republicans
don't say a word about it. This stuff makes us
look like a joke. This woman is one of 435 members
of Congress. We are a global laughingstock because
of people like her and Ruben, like a
bobblehead, nodding along, just nodding along.
It's embarrassing, folks. It's I'm embarrassed
for both of them. I'm blushing for both of them.